[Applauso]
[Musica]
essere Green
o non essere Green
Questo è il problema
vi porto nel 2003 nel 2004 ero un
giovane architetto e Frequentavo i primi
incontri le prime fiere di in Italia
sulla bioarchitettura che poi a mio
avviso la bioarchitettura non esiste
esiste la buona architettura la buona
edilizio in realtà vedevo sempre le
solite facce i soliti tecnici e allora
da giovani architetto e mi sono
domandato Ma come facciamo a trasferire
questi contenuti
all'utente finale che poi è il nostro
committente che poi siete voi come
facciamo a formarlo
[Musica]
attraverso l'intrattenimento televisivo
perché no E allora ho creato ho avuto la
fortuna di creare un Format TV e e ho
girato il mondo per più di tre anni
andando a raccontare le migliori
pratiche di bioarchitettura di
efficientamento energetico di vita
sostenibile
e ho visto cose che voi umani non potete
nemmeno
immaginare
e adesso vi porto a fare un piccolo
viaggio
[Musica]
Ok Australia deserto australiano
Questa è una casa
autosufficiente completamente quindi è
staccata sia dalla rete idrica che dalla
rete elettrica dove l'unica acqua
utilizzabile e quella piovana e dove
l'unica energia utilizzabile è quella
del Sole è stata costruita costruita
dagli aborigeni con con mattoni in terra
cruda e la padrona di casa è una
settantenne che ci vive pure da solo
capisci
qua in Brasile Questo è un grattacielo
che gira di 360 gradi andando a seguire
il percorso del sole ma ogni piano può
girare di 360 gradi Quindi ognuno dei
proprietari può andare a prendere la
migliore incidenza solare durante la
giornata
costruito con materiali edili naturali e
dell'economia circolare capisci
qua siamo nella New Messico nel deserto
del New Messico case autosufficienti
costruite anche queste in terra e paglia
ma con tutti i materiali di scarto di
risulta riciclati e con un'attenzione
particolare alla bioclimatica cioè al
rapporto diretto con l'intorno con il
sole e con i denti alla fine di questo
viaggio necessariamente ho dovuto
cambiare proprio la il mio modo di
pensare la progettazione del costruito e
ho iniziato a dare più attenzione agli
ingredienti della ricetta piuttosto che
al cake design
e voi
continuate a farvi costruire le case in
maniera tradizionale
[Musica]
passiamo più del 90% del nostra vita del
nostro quotidiano all'interno degli
spazi confinati e cioè le nostre case le
scuole gli uffici le palestre i teatri e
non sappiamo che l'inquinamento indoor e
cinque volte superiore rispetto
all'esterno c'è un rapporto di 5 a 1
e non sappiamo che i 2,7%
delle malattie nel mondo deriva
dall'inquinamento indoor e non sappiamo
che il 95% delle sostanze nocive che noi
ci respiriamo ci respiriamo a casa negli
uffici nelle scuole e Teatri
La maggior parte dell'inquinamento
indoor deriva dai voc i voc sono i
componenti organici volatili che per il
20% sono emessi dagli arredi oppure
dalle nostre abitudini ma per l'80% sono
emessi dalla nostra terza pelle
la seconda sono gli abiti che Indossiamo
la terza pelle è l'involucro che ci
abbraccia dove viviamo
[Musica]
le emissioni in realtà derivano proprio
anche da tutta
elementi nascosti chiamiamoli così c'è
da tutta la stratigrafia delle pareti
fino ad arrivare poi alle tinte alle
vernici agli impregnanti
ci sono nel mercato
dei materiali edili naturali materiali
basso emissivi che vengono utilizzati
come isolanti termici acustici
igrometrici resistenti alla muffa
traspiranti resistenti all'acqua al
calore
resistenti al fuoco e questa tenetela
e Allora signori iniziamo il primo
protagonista della serata è il sughero
tostato Questo è un pannello in sughero
tostato dove all'interno non c'è nessun
elemento chimico perché a differenza del
sughero biondo il sughero biondo ha
delle resine sintetiche come come
eleganti per legarlo questo invece la
sua il suo elegante è uno zucchero che
produce direttamente lui la superina che
fuoriesce ad elevate temperature di
cottura ed è per questo che è un sughero
tostato
quindi quando andate a realizzare le
vostre case
abbiamo detto della Prova del Fuoco Voi
sapete quanto ci mette un pannello in
sughero tostato a differenza del
pannello di sughero biondo a prendere
fuoco
circa un'ora
[Musica]
Voi sapete quanto ci mette a prendere
fuoco un pannello in polistirene in
polistirolo derivante dalla
petrolchimica 1 2 3 basta
in solo tre secondi prende fuoco
e voi continuate a col farvi costruire
le case in maniera tradizionale oppure
parliamo sempre di cappotto il cappotto
termico No il cappotto dei nostri mobili
Ormai se ne parla dappertutto ma voi il
vostro cappotto invernale lo preferisco
lo preferite di lana o di materiali
sintetico
signori
Questo è un prodotto in lana di pecora
sarda vergine
la lana
ed è composto per un 75% di materiali di
scarto perché sono è la lana che che non
viene utilizzata per gli abiti o per i
tappeti quindi verrebbe bruciata e uno
scarto e per un 25% da fibre di
canapa fibre naturali e Ha una
consistenza che somiglia anche ai
prodotti che ci sono nel commercio E
leggete No perché non ho girato Ecco ed
è utilizzato come isolamento termico
acustico e ha una gestione dell'umidità
ambientale interna importantissimo è una
cosa che io domando sempre e dico sempre
ma come fate a mettere all'interno delle
vostre case delle vostre Mura dei
prodotti sintetici che per produrli c'è
voluta più energia di quella che poi
andrete a risparmiare all'interno delle
vostre case con quel materiale
e voi continuate a farvi costruire le
vostre case in maniera tradizionale
oppure Eccolo
il biomattone in calce e canapa Questo è
un prodotto massivo fa Massa termica e
un mattone fa tutto lui bisogna essere
solo posizionato non ha neanche bisogno
di una stratigrafia di materiali diversi
e addirittura il materiali di scarto che
vengono lavorati in cantiere possono
essere rielaborati e utilizzati come
intonaco interno ed intonaco esterno in
modo che non ci sia neanche
discontinuità di materiale utile per
l'abbattimento dei ponti termici quindi
crea un ambiente sano ed uno dei
materiali migliori per le case in Zeb le
case a energia quasi Zero
facciamo così
[Musica]
andiamo avanti quindi entriamo fin
dentro casa le pitture Quanti di voi
avranno comprato le pitture naturali
all'acqua
no E ci avete pittato casa
l'acqua non è un elegante
c'è un po' meno di chimica ma per
normativa è diluita nell'acqua le vere
pitture naturali sono le pitture che
hanno come eleganti il latte il tuorlo
d'uovo dei eleganti vegetali e poi sono
colorati con pigmenti naturali non
sintetici
un'altra finitura meravigliosa sono le
finiture in argilla che è un materiale
vivo che vuol dire
l'argilla assorbe i voc e la CO2 che noi
mettiamo dentro casa è un materiale vivo
è un po' come le piante fa il lavoro
delle piante
E allora voi
continuate a farvi costruire la casa in
maniera tradizionale
a questo punto diventa a mio avviso
fondamentale
No andiamo avanti andiamo avanti voglio
voglio scendere ancora di più il parquet
Il parquet
è protagonista nelle vostre case ce
l'abbiamo in tanti ma voi sapete
esattamente se è certificato se fa parte
di una catena di custodia Che vi tutela
Cioè se il materiale che è stato la
materia prima è stata lavorata in
foreste gestito in maniera sostenibile
non con dei disboscamenti tutti i
materiali che sono stati utilizzati
dentro Sapete quali sono fanno parte di
una catena di custodia poi lo vuoi lo
andate a mettere nelle vostre case
magari sotto Gli mettete un pavimento
radiante col caldo vai poi i bambini no
che vivono al 90% della loro vita a
terra
Allora
ciclo produttivo noi adesso con il cibo
siamo un po' tutti quanti attenti
abbiamo imparato andare a vedere no la
scheda dietro capire la materia prima
dove è stata creata prodotta il ciclo
produttivo finché arriva nelle vostre
tavole e nei vostri corpi perché con
l'involucro che ci circonda e che ci
abbraccia i nostri vite ancora no
diventa fondamentale a questo punto la
progettazione della salubrità ambientale
interna e quindi la scelta dei materiali
ma proprio come un principio di
prevenzione per la vostra salute
scegliere i materiali basso emissivi
scegliere i materiali edili naturali è
un po' come
togliere le medicine dai vostri comodini
e voi per il vostro futuro
continuerebbe a farvi costruire le case
in maniera tradizionale
Eh no E allora Impegnatevi non lasciate
a noi tecnici o all'impresa la scelta
Impegnatevi voi a scegliere i migliori
ingredienti
per la vostra casa sana
[Applauso]